so where will tom brady be in
2020 people have yet to really wake up
to the strong possibility that he will
leave the patriots i think most people
take the position
will believe it when we see it well
michael irvin gave us something to
ponder on friday the cowboys hall of
fame receivers on weei and he said that
quote some very significant people and
quote told irvin that the cowboys may
pursue
tommy in free agency now
irvin would go to twitter to say that
those very significant people do not
include cowboys owner jerry jones or
anyone else associated with the team he
still said very significant people told
him tom brady could end up with the
cowboys peter you know on one hand i
look at this and i say there's no way in
hell that's going to happen they have
dak prescott they want dak prescott he's
their future he's their present on the
other hand i look at how prescott is
squeezing jerry jones right now and
jerry jones is desperate to win a super
bowl
would he be willing to get what he could
for dak prescott tag and trade
and bring in tom brady and load up the
cannon with mike mccarthy for a one year
run to try to win a super bowl i mean of
all the crazy things we've seen in the
nfl over the past few years this one
would not be the craziest if jerry jones
would decide to do it
i don't think it's that crazy either i
think it's unlikely but i think the
biggest question in that scenario mike
is what would you get for dak prescott
i mean the big question right now is
what really is dak prescott's value look
he's a very good quarterback
but he's also due
to get a huge payday so
would you
for instance
trade if you're a team that needs them
if you're a team that needs a
quarterback would you let's say you're
the chargers
would you trade the whatever it is the
seventh pick in the second round maybe
plus something else
um
for dak prescott and then immediately
pay him
35 million dollars a year which we all
keep hearing that the charges are not
exactly flush with cash
and again
i
that's what would be so strange and
that's why this entire offseason is
bizarro world
because they're going to be three or
four things that are gonna happen like
with dak prescott whatever happens that
people are gonna say oh my god i never
saw that coming
now
jerry might emotionally want to do this
i bet today if you asked him who would
you rather have your quarterback in 2020
dak prescott or tom brady at 43 he would
say tom brady
that's why
he's got a couple of really good
personnel guys
uh and his son you know stephen jones to
talk him off this ledge because you
can't build a team for the long haul if
you're talking about getting rid of the
guy who you've thought all along as your
franchise quarterback so you could have
one year maybe
two with a 43 year old quarterback
and i'm fascinated by
what it really would
take to sign dak prescott if he were a
free agent free and clear what would his
market be because see the problem is
once you start using franchise tag
the contract is driven by the value of
the tag if they use the exclusive tag on
dak prescott current calculations put
that at 33.4 million for the first year
20 raise for 2021 makes it 40 million
for a second year that's how you start
putting together these gigantic numbers
and justifying them market value who
knows we won't know and we'll never know
until he's on the open market um is
there a team out there that would pay
him 35 million is there a team out there
that would pay him 35 million and give
the cowboys real value i don't know uh
and it and it could be that the cowboys
just get exasperated by dak because dak
is doing what few quarterbacks ever do
he is driving a really hard bargain he
hasn't accepted
significant offers that have been on the
table because he believes he's worth
more and he believes he can get more and
he is pushing and pushing and pushing
them and we know how they like to get
guys to do business on their terms you
know at some point jerry and steven may
say we've done everything we can to get
this guy to sign the kind of deal we
want him to sign he won't do it let's
move on to plan b and if plan b is tom
brady there have been worse plan b's in
the history of the nfl
well not only that mike but you have
raised this issue a couple of times and
it's really important to know
the dallas cowboys need their
quarterback
in the building on april 5th
you know they need their quarterback in
the building then because it's a new
offense
and especially if it's going to be a new
quarterback he's got to learn all his
teammates so in my opinion if they know
that there's a good chance dak prescott
isn't going to show up till labor day
weekend and he'll just take these huge
fines then i think they might say might
okay maybe we do need to go to plan b
now
an amazing scenario fueled by jerry
jones burning desire to get a super bowl
now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports